El paso del huracán por la zona oeste de
Florida ha dejado como ven un panorama
desolador cientos de casas y negocios
han quedado completamente destruidos
caminando por este lugar nos encontramos
con un montón de lugares completamente
desaparecidos mezclados con lodo también
cristales hierro y muchísimos escombros
también las carreteras están
completamente de vehículos desplazados
también de barcos lo que da una idea de
la gran marejada ciclónica esa marejada
el ciclónica catastrófica de la que
advertían los los meteorólogos por ese
aumento del nivel del mar ahora Florida
empieza a amanecer algunos vecinos
también empiezan a acercarse hasta este
lugar donde entró por este sitio parte
del huracán Ian y también algunos
equipos de emergencia que están tratando
de auxiliar a las personas que quedaron
atrapadas aquí a pesar de que muchas de
ellas recibieron orden obligatoria de
evacuación pese a eso prefirieron
desafiar los embates y la peligrosidad
de este huracán y prefirieron quedarse
en este lugar